oh man
I wanted this to be the scariest
depiction of Dracula ever there's
something potent about that mythology
everyone knows fear and I think Dracula
represents that this chapter of Bram
Stoker's Dracula hasn't been told
what actually happened on the ship that
transported Dracula from the port of
Varna to England
is by itself just fascinating
[Music]
foreign
Dracula is trying to find more people
more blood a better place to feed this
looks like a bite what better place than
the huge Brazilian of London search the
ship
everywhere
it's monster time when the lights go ill
I really love this alien style story set
on the ocean in 1897 and with Dracula
instead of the alien monster it was just
all the elements were really exciting
there's no way off this ship and that
evil is lurking right there we've yet to
experience this extreme emotion of fear
but safely
may God have mercy on us all he's the
perfect monster you look at the images
and it's just magic man it's magic
it's Dracula and I want to kill the
cusset thing
foreign